OR FIVE HOURS.
FRED>> NK PEYTONALSH, SO MUCH F.
RUSH TT  A EMBAS EVACUATED.
RTMENT AEREM FLABEENNG A
DIAMHEHING
OTRS OUTN D
NTS TO
DI  KABULE BEENEN A ARE GOIO 'RF
IS G T
UL.
THE  FOLKS THAT ARE STILTHERE AA
OU THEWN THE AMERICAN FLAG
ST
ATE EVACUANGMBEC UDIRE WIT TS,
PROPAGANDA AGAINST
ATMEN,OULD THEY TAR, W PEARS SI
THHERES AGE UT HOW DLK IT'SO NOE
RTPOSP
N
EMBASS
RTE TY BLINKEN
TODADEND THIS HAL
LLLAN
PLACE.
U.S.
THEY HSUTE NU.S.
PEL VE
TALIBAN INNED ATOE E
MUCH MORE PIE
BIDEN ADMINISTRATION EXPECTED.WE
AT IS ONOFREASONS THAT LOT OT T
BA IS THE WHITE HOUSYIWH FOR?NGE
orter: YEAH, THERE'S NO  THIS I
MOMENT NEARLY 20 YEARS AFTER THE
U. SEET
TALIBAN FORCAT OTE BTHAT.S.-LED
INVASION COMING BAO POTAKING CO
PRESIDENTITAINLY CLDA MOMENT
PRO THAT O THAT OF NOW THERE IS
RETURN FROM HI
AND NOT THE STILL UNDERWAY
MADT WHET
ELY FROM THET.HOTHE WHITOF THE I
THOSS IN ADVISERS AS
THESISNGN,
EMPTCE TABLE WH E AL
S D
WE'LL DE WHITE
INGTO DO,HIS AS A
SAFENDRDLYTHOSE ARE S T DE.
IS THE EXITS
SOMETHING THATT GO
INITIALLANTICIPATED.
FACT T TO THE SEVERAROOPS INTOAL
U.SONNEL THGHY
NOTING THEEDE TALIBAN ADVANCE AN
OF IT SEEMS AMONG THOS THE , THT
D HA THESE
CONTINGE TT.
U THE COMING
DAS TH ILL IN.W RIVE AENAL
WITHDRAW AS  JERAMOND AT THE
NKAPEC
COLLA EI IN BEING MP U.SAWAL19.
ES.EFWEEEG SAIGON ATOL FEND T
. D RUSHE
S N R AF MORNI PUSHED U.S. SECR.
AVDIGOHEILIATI
SAIGON.
AREN'T WALREAD MSTAI?
RE IS NO
WE WENT TO 20 YEARS  WITH ONE MD
WAS TO DEA WHO
THAW?E EVE ST BACK.THISERTSONHN
E  NIC
KNOW, HOIME, Y
IMPACT OWHAT DMM
ULE, AGA
AFGHANISTAN?
>> Reporter:HINK
NGOUNTRIESSTAND DESI .
RECOGNIZE, NOT RUSH  RECOGNIZE
E BA A LEGITIMATE
GOVERNMENT BECAUSE, OF COURS
THAT WAS PART OF T
NEGOTIATIONS WITH .OUF NAL RULEH
IDN'T
THEY STOLEGH
SEEN THAT THE  RKTHMINISTER OATN
GOING T
ONE COUNTRS,
KI POTENTIALLY AWE
PA OF ANT TO RECOGNIZE TAS LEGIE
THAT LISO THAT.
WOULD E TH A
INTERNATIONAL FRAC OVER
WHAT TO DO
I THINK YOE UNITED
STATES REPUTAT
AGTARNISHED.T BIDEN CAME TO OF
ON ODEMOY.THEYEN B
PE WUTEI,  T RUSOWER.IDE
SEY CAN  M AND FOO THE
FOR THEIFA
CAN THEY DAYFE